[موسيقى]
جريمه اخرى تضاف الى جرائم العدو الصهيوني
في مخيم المغازي قصف مدرسه تابعه للوكاله
لانور في مخيم المغازي وهي تعتبر من
المناطق الامنه الذي نزح اليها السكان في
قطاع غزه تم قصف هذه المدرسه بما ادى الى
استشهاد عشرات من المواطنين واصابه
العشرات اخرين هذهه هي جرائم العدو
الصهيوني ضد المدنيين والعزل في قطاع غزه
وفي مخيم المغازي هذا المخيم المحاصر منذ
اربع ايام على التوالي من دبابات العدو
الصهيوني مصابين ملقون على الارض حتى
يرتقون الى الله شهداء نتيجه عدم وجود
مركز صحي او اسعافات داخل المخيم المحاصر
منذ ثلاث
ايام
نحن امام جريمه كبيره في مخيم المغازي
استهداف النازحين من القطاع داخل مدرسه
تابعه للوكاله وهي تعتبر هذه المدرسه امنه
للمواطنين معترف بها من المنظمه الدوليه
التابعه للوكاله
لانور يسكن في هذه المدرسه ما يقارب 5000
مواطن 5000 مواطن
تم استهدافها مساء امس بما ادى الى ارتقاء
العديد من الشهداء
والجرحى